well covent has forced the organizers of
ces to make some major changes to this
year's show in order to bring back
face-to-face events madison kimbrough
checked out the convention center and
shares how the show is preparing for an
opening on wednesday madison
the energy was definitely high denise as
we spoke to a ces rep and vendors that
are just really excited and happy to
attend in person once again
coming
back here
with that face-to-face interaction it's
something that the industry
wants it's something that the industry
needs ces 2022 is almost here and with
people arriving from 160 different
countries and 2200 exhibitors on site
this year's show is set to be a nice
welcome back after a year of going
digital and being socially distant we're
happy to present in person so we can
show our great product to
people this year's event is hybrid and
will end a day earlier than usual
organizers making that change in
response to a rise in covet cases ending
the show a day early was just another
way to add
another layer of protection and
precaution jason soto who runs vu studio
says he's happy with how ces is handling
things i think it's actually a really
smart move on ces part
they obviously saw somewhat of a
reduction right that they didn't
publicize but somewhat of a reduction in
the number of attendees so let people
be at the show for you know three days
wednesday thursday friday and then off
they go it reduces exposure the annual
trade show is requiring proof of
vaccination and masks must be worn
indoors
optional self-testing kits will also be
given out to those that attend and the
show wraps up on friday at the las vegas
speedway reporting live in front of the
convention center madison kimbrough live
local now
popular